so thank you for coming we would like to
tell you today how to use recurrent
- motor learners knowledge I'm whatever
this is McCoy
and we are from the company called
Pearson and just to give you some
context Pearson is working or active and
in education sector so it is providing a
learning platforms for higher education
market in United States and you can
think about those platforms as something
similar to Coursera or EDX so learners
can do some homeworks test on those
platforms there are exercises some kind
of tutorials that guide learners through
some topics instructional videos and
things like that so because of that the
problems that we are working on during
our work are usually connected with the
process of learning and one of those
problems that we would like to tell you
about is called knowledge tracing and
the basic idea of knowledge tracing is
that we would like to be able based on
some learners interactions so you can
think about those interactions like for
example okay it seems to be working now
sorry for that so as I said we would
like to be able based on learners
interactions so for example by the
responses to exercises or we can think
about it broader like how often they log
into this platform or if they finish
their homeworks just before a deadline
or if they kind of speed this work even
leave to the period that they have
available so we'd like to be able based
on those interactions to be able to
assess learners skills and based on
those this assessment to be able to
predict if their next interaction will
be core
or not so just to make this problem
slightly more concrete you can imagine
that we have some learner and it
completed item one and I tend to
correctly and it provided wrong response
to item three two times so based on this
if we assume that the skill one is
needed to correctly response to item one
and two we can assume that he is quite
proficient with this skill and if he
failed to provide two times the correct
answer to item three he's probably not
proficient with the skill and based on
those inferences we can assume that he
will be likely to provide correct answer
to item four that requires q1 and will
probably fail on item fifth that
requires this second skill so you might
ask why this is important and kind of
goal here is to create a more adaptive
learning experience for learners that
will ultimately simulate one-on-one
human tutoring so you probably can
imagine that if you have a teacher that
kind of works with you on some specific
topic he is able to adapt to your skill
level and provide you with just the
exercises and instructional content that
you need at the moment but this kind of
not everyone can afford for a private
instructor and you would like to be able
to replicate this kind of learning with
some AI or learning machine learning so
we could use this kind of system in many
different ways for example we could
create a practice module that would be
tailored to the needs of particular
learners so we could address their
weaknesses
we could also inform learners if they
are able to do if they are likely to
pass the next test that is upcoming for
them or if they should focus on any
specific areas to kind of increase their
chances of passing it we could also
provide this kind of
information to teachers so if they have
some kind of class we could do some
aggregate statistics and for example
point that this class is particularly
weak in this area and he should revise
this material to kind of help them to
pass particular curse so if we know the
problem we can kind of search for the
data that we can use and one of the
advantages of Pearson is that it
operates on the market for quite some
time
and we have a lot of data so for example
for single Pearson product week and you
can think about this product as a kind
of a title so for example introduction
to algebra that was translated into some
online courseware so for one particular
title we have something like 30,000
sequences and those sequences can be
length of those sequences can range from
25 to even above 3,000 elements and also
learners can complete one of above 8,000
unique exercises so there is lot of
variability in this data and you can do
a lot with this data but on the other
hand it is quite challenging to work
with so one thing is a volume it is hard
to work when you have that huge amounts
of data second thing is that it is
usually sequence data in which sequence
matters and in this case not every model
can handle this type of data and you
usually need some specific models that
are able to handle it and also one of
the kind of new ones that might be
difficult here is that those sequences
don't have the same length so sometimes
you need to fill in the gaps so each
kind of each sequence have the same
length and it is then a die motor is
able to consume this kind of data and
also we have a mix of Catterick
categorical and binary variables so
we've got a question I did that
represents the kind of specific exercise
that a learner completed but also we
have for example a flag that the
response work was correct or not so we
can kind of we were looking around for
different approaches to how to solve
this problem and there are many
established models for example IRT based
models that use logistic regression to
kind of predict based on the learner
skills and difficulty of the exercise if
the response will be correct or not
we have also models that you use
Bayesian inference that and try to kind
of approach this problem from this angle
but we were trying to come up with
something new and we kind of encountered
something called a deep knowledge
tracing and it sounded cool so we try to
experiment with it so just to give you
some understanding of what deep
knowledge tracing is the basic idea is
that we take those learners interaction
and just feed them into recurrent neural
network and the goal of this network is
to try to predict the result of the next
interaction and just to remind you
recommend to neural network is just an
air network with a loop inside and this
kind of loop allows information to
persist so after in each element of the
C in each time step we fit a neuron or
this hidden layer with kind of the
exercise that a learner completed and in
our case and then also an input for the
hidden layers is a result of a previous
step
so in the context of a deep knowledge
tracing the kind of this kind of hidden
unit holds in itself the kind of
encoding that represents a learner
knowledge state so this based on those
interaction it kind of creates some
representation of the learners knowledge
and based on this representation
it is able to predict if this
interaction if a learner will be able to
correctly or incorrectly respond to the
whole range of exercises that we are
interested in so just to make it easier
for you to visualize the output of the
model we can think about it as this kind
of heat map and on the x-axis we can see
that a learner completed several
exercises and there are represented by
the first kind of thing here is
represents the ID of exercises so this
first element of the sequence represents
that a learner completed 55 exercise and
he answered it correctly and after each
of those responses we see that model
updates the probability that learn
learner knows or don't know the
particular skill and as you can see
after correct responses this kind of
fields tend to become darker and after
incorrect response they are usually
getting lighter but as you can see those
motors are not yet perfect and this is
kind of funny thing happening after
second incorrect response and the model
suddenly comes to conclusion that
learner is more proficient with those
skills then after the first bad response
but in general those kind of prediction
makes sense and interesting kind of
challenge here is how to model how to
input those sequences of correct
responses with their ID to the neural
net and we've got basically two options
here one is one code encoding that is
not particularly interesting but the
second thing is entity embedding that
you can do interesting things with and
just to remind you entity embeddings is
just representing categorical variables
as vectors of numbers so it is similar
concept as word embeddings in NLP and it
has been used successfully in many
Cargill competition like taxi prediction
or aasman chand and he
a graph from a Rosemont challenge in
which the aim was to predict the amount
of sales in each of the rows monsters
that were located in different cities
and the guys that created this model
represented the city that rose monster
was located in as a entity and bedding
and after some transformation those kind
of variables location of those points on
this graph resembled the location of the
cities on the German map so it is kind
of interesting a side thing that came
out from this model and similarly with
deepness tracing
if you encode particular skills as
entity embedding the side product of
this model is a domain map of the kind
of a subject that you are working with
so here for example the creators of this
paper was were working with canned data
so can is a website that teaches the
math and when they kind of tried this
deep knowledge tracing the kind of
particle topics in the mouth domain were
kind of clustered by their similarity
and also the relations between some
topics emerged for example the post
requisite prerequisite relation so you
can think of it that for example to
master multiplication you need to master
the addition first and this kind of
motor was able to came out with those
kind of realized relations by itself so
it is pretty interesting side product of
this model and just to kind of wrap up
this theoretical introduction to these
kind of models here is the comparison of
the performance of deep knowledge
tracing models based on different
educational datasets so that's it is
usually a case when the first paper of
on deep knowledge tracing came out the
outers claim that this is far superior
than any other model but with time some
data processing we found that kind of
led to the overstatement of the
performance of the model but also
creators that work on other models start
to tweak them to match this performance
and here you can see the comparison with
modified Bayesian models so the creators
added some aspects like forgetting or
kind of relations between skills and
were able to match or surpass the
performance of deep knowledge tracing
models but the kind of elegance of a
deep knowledge tracing is that you don't
need to have a broad domain knowledge to
be able to mate make all those tweaks
you just can take a recurrent neural
network out of the box and just put the
data you have into it and its
performance will be quite fine and you
won't need to kind of tweak it or no
interior its internals to that great
extent so I'm passing the second part of
a presentation to McCoy right so I'm
going to talk about what we actually did
so how did the model structure look like
so I was talking about you know the the
data the input data that we had so we
had the raw results and we had a
question ID so this is like if the
answer was correct or not so it's like a
sequence of ones and zeroes and this
this is the sequence of essentially
exercise IDs so we made it like a unique
identifier so we connect concatenated
the exercise ID with with the response
so we had like you know each like
correct and incorrect answer to a single
activity where like you know separates
from each other so different categories
and so we had a lot of categories in the
end so we didn't like an embedding layer
over here just you know if we want a how
to encode it we would have like a huge
matrix so we did an embedding layer
right here and we put it into a nest
lsdm layer and on the output you have a
dense layer and the dense layer is the
size of the
is the size of a number of the of the
activities because you can like somehow
think of it like that it outputs the
probability of the correct answer for
each activity like you said like you saw
on this on this heat map that matter
which was showing so right so how did
how did we actually do this so we wrote
everything using low-level tensorflow
code I don't know how many of you are
familiar with writing low-level
tensorflow code some resonant yeah so we
did this like on purpose so actually we
wanted to have like the finer the finest
grain control we can over what is
happening in the in the network so just
to be able to tweak the method a bit so
writing global about tensor flow code is
yeah a bit funny and a bit painful at
the same time so I'm going to talk a bit
about this so the recurrent layer had
200 hidden units the embedding size was
50 the loss function was a weighted
cross entropy and it was kind of like a
modified one because it was taking
waviness into account so to account what
Matt was talking about
so actually you know if your predictions
changes dramatically if for example you
know drastically after after after an
answer that's probably bad because you
want them to change just slightly so
this is like like the weeks with it and
we use the Animus as the optimizer and
essentially we just left like 10% of
observations for for testing yeah
the next question correct so that the
chewy that you are going to get this
correct in if it was asked like like it
was the next question right so yeah so
this is how it works thinks yeah and we
were training this on AWS so and on the
machine that used single GPU so
essentially the the cheapest one that
that uses that uses GPU so what we did
at the very beginning so we were trying
to this was somehow like you know
described in the papers so we were
trying to do some code sanity checks so
we wrote the structure in the in we
wrote the tensorflow code and we fed fed
the data that was used in the paper just
to figure out if we don't have any
mistakes and this is really a nice thing
to do if you if you can because it's
quite easy to make a mistake while Y
designing your structure and so if you
have a data and some other so results of
others so you can just fit the data and
check if there are more or less the same
and like as you see the dr so some of
their like hyper parameters like number
of views etc are a bit different so
there are like slightly slightly
different but you know some of them for
example on the assessments 2009 data
it's like pretty like almost exactly the
same so well that we concluded that it's
our structure is fine right so we wrote
the code correctly so what were the
results on our data when we fed our data
this is really interesting so we were
getting the AUC of almost 0.9 so this
looks Wow like with it is our data such
great results unfortunately this is not
so great
even though the other metrics were also
promising so we were gonna like f1 score
of 0 88 TPR 0 8 DNR 0 83 however the
data said that we are reasoning is is
unbalanced and the papers were just just
reporting AUC so it was really like
really like hard to compare so we think
we are doing quite ok but the comparison
might not be that that valuable in the
end so let's let's come to the lessons
learn because this is really like a fun
fun part I think so
yeah so the first problem we have
encountered so we started essentially
like you know we figure out maybe we'll
some will try some you know some
recreant neural networks on this problem
so we did this for the first time and so
when we figure out the code like from
the internet it turned out that the
training one April Apoc takes seven
hours so that was pretty long on the
machine with the GPU and there are a
couple of problems with the code with
we've actually written so you can find
something like this in like majority of
examples across the internet so the
examples are using something like like
the basic lsdm self from the errand and
cell module of tensorflow so we use the
we use tensorflow like i don't know but
but before the two zeros so not we did
it's like on the beginning of the year
so two zero was not yet released then so
in the in most of the examples you could
find something like this and it turned
out that is incredibly slow it just
works on you know on some playground
examples but not on real data if you
have like huge amount of data that that
will be very slow so instead we can use
a function that is dedicated to use on
the GPU so for example we use there is
like a c UD n NL s TM and from another
module there is a similar function just
a bit just a bit different naming and at
the time of our product of the product
when when we wrote the project this one
had issues so I'm going to talk this in
in a minute but essentially you know do
not use the functions from the examples
that they won't work well I think so
that was that was one of our mistakes so
there's another piece of code that can
be found in in a majority of examples
across the internet so and it's like
that for each epoch essentially for each
batch just train on this batch and
you're going to be fine just iterate
through batches right so in in a loop
well like passing the data in batches
through this like fit deked argument of
a session run is again incredibly slow
you need to like load if you if you do
this like you don't all the data at once
and then just feed the batches then it's
really really slow and there is
something that is called like data input
pipeline
in terms of tensorflow dataset api and
it works like a charm and it's really
really fast so it reads and processes
the data from disk like batch by batch
so not loading all the data at once and
it allows mapping custom functions that
transforms the data anyway we want just
like on-the-fly before feeding this to a
neural network and it has like a lot of
building and handy functions so
especially for neural networks for us it
was very handy to you know because we
had like sequences of very various
lengths so from like few elements to
like few thousand elements so we need to
handle this somehow and it it was really
helpful to have those functions and it
runs the processing on CPU and so to
just make a clear distinction between
data processing and the actual training
which should happen essentially on a GPU
if you are using a GPU machine so
monitoring GPU usage is also very handy
here so it might help you to to
determine what that you might have like
issues with the PI with your data input
pipeline so this is how it looks like if
you if you just do this so it's it's
quite funny that for example CPU is
preparing the data and then the GPU is
idling right so this is what's the first
scenario that is not going to work very
well and then the CPU sends the data to
GPU and it actually takes some time so
it should be even like a gap in here and
then it's training and after that it
prepares like it prepares another batch
and you know those there are a lot of
idling of CPUs and GPUs over there so
you can definitely do better because you
can prepare your first batch fit this to
a GPU start training and in the meantime
just prepare the second batch and this
is not even the most optimal scenario
but in general this is this is the case
so you want essentially the GPU usage to
be high as high as possible all the time
because if it's not then you are wasting
your processing resources and it's
always good to to monitor that so after
we apply all those improvements so
change those functions applied the data
set improve pipeline the time of
straining cronic book was reduced from
seven hours to seven minutes so that's
like a huge huge significant significant
improvement so this is you know the
scale so the second problem was that
actually results were
wrong so the you know the thing is not
to trust tensorflow in all cases so we
replaced this like basic lsdm cell with
the CU tienen el SDM cell from the TF
contract module and it turned out it
speeds up the training it works on GPU
pretty well but it gives us different
results and like significantly different
than all the datasets we've tried so we
thought like well something is wrong and
like deep in the source code of github
we found a sentence that is saying that
job's functions are mathematically
different from their counterparts so no
one ever knows like what what does it
mean and there was no like no
information in there in the
documentation so we thought yeah well
but so we know one documented what those
what those differences are and we fixed
this essentially by using the function
from the Charis module so I would advise
you always to go not to use the the
contrib module it contains some
functions that might not be at like
working very well so the problem number
three was that there were like a couple
of data scientists working on it at the
same time so and we wanted to track the
experiments somehow and how to do that
right how to track experiments should we
be noting it down like on paper or
should we note it down in an excel file
those computations happen on some
external machines so you know the output
some you know some numbers and you know
how to how to note it down not to lose
those experiments to track them and to
to compare results so definitely not in
the next two files not on paper so we
decided to use ml flow tracking on data
breaks and it allows to lock all the
information needed to interpret but also
like reproduce the experiments so
especially like hyper parameters use so
we can just retrain using the same
parameters so we are logging all this so
we have results we have hyper parameters
we have like versions of the model so so
essentially we can we can reproduce the
experiments and compare the experiments
between between each other so that's
that's that's very helpful so
summarizing all this so in terms of dkt
it's a very promising architecture for
tracking learners knowledge the relative
simplicity and then good performances is
definitely something that we want to
explore
further and there's still some room for
improvement so for example as you have
you've seen like those like you know
probably's that are not updated
perfectly in all the cases and
interpretability of these could be an
issue essentially because you know like
it's a black box model so it's not very
easy to to interpret that and in terms
of technical stuff so make sure always
to monitor GPU usage so this is like I
think a very common mistake if you if
you begin to work with neural networks
that you know if training takes a lot of
time you just yeah setup is like a
bigger machine like that cost like $100
per per hour and it won't really help if
your code is suboptimal so so that's
that's very important to keep in mind
and be careful with tensorflow so that's
also the case I don't know if they're
supposed to to zero probably fixes some
of the problems but again like the
technology evolves so fast
that there are probably bugs anyway
somewhere so I really encourage you to
go to this website so this is the
website of our team and there you can
find like you know the news about what
we do but also we we are searching for
people so we are searching for for
interns and we're searching for a
regular employees so if you're
interested go there you will find a
Facebook page and you will find the job
descriptions and you know descriptions
of who we actually it's right now so I
really encourage to go there and and
apply and I think there is one more
thing so we have a couple of spare
t-shirts right here so if you want there
is a guy like in the very back like that
has the t-shirt so that says like AI so
here's our model so if you want that
kind of t-shirts there are a few way the
front so feel free feel free to just
grab one and thank you
[Applause]
so a one of the application could be we
initially faulted about some kind of
system that could inform instructors
about the struggling students so for
example if we kind of predict that this
particular learner will not be able to
handle a material that is upcoming in
the course we could just inform an
instructor that maybe it would be worth
to kind of contact with these students
and try to can fill those gaps in his
knowledge so this is kind of more like
informing instructor but we are also
thinking about kind of adaptive practice
modules that would be able to
automatically generate some kind of
homeworks for learners or instructional
content that could be able to fill those
gaps instead of instructor
[Laughter]
the thing is that actually I can also
duh the first there are two questions I
guess so the first one is what is the
difference between this basic lsdm cell
and those see you DNA analysts like lsdm
cells so those were like just optimized
to use with the GPU so that they are
just utilizing the full GPU power I
don't know like what mathematically does
it really mean and in terms of like the
difference between the two to two
functions that says like C UDN and
something I don't really know that that
was the problem so so I just found that
they are mathematically different but I
don't know in what sense because that
was not documented anywhere but so what
do you mean about by parallelizable I
think it runs on a single GPU in that
case so it's not like running on
parallel GPUs because it's it's like
another problem and I think it's quite
quite you know challenge another
challenge to have it running on multiple
GPUs at the same time so here we just
use a single GPU so it was not paralyzed
in any way does it answer the question
okay so we can talk in a break but yeah
make sure you got the proper size of the
t-shirt
[Applause]